Let's go to our caller from the two zero three
area code.
Who is calling today from two zero three
Oh, David?
Yes.
Oh, Hey, uh, my name is Josh.
I'm from Connecticut and I just, uh, I just
watched, uh, Trump's speech this morning.
The response to, uh, you know, the attack
on the Iraqi base.
Right.
And, uh, you see, he seemed really tired.
He seems like he just woke up.
Uh, but yeah.
Uh, and you know, basically it was short.
He said like, you know, it doesn't seem like
we're doing any sort of military strike.
Like as of now, we don't really know.
Yeah.
The impression I got from that speech was
he actually seems okay.
Take it like, as I said on the program, um,
the day of the, of the strikes, Iran kind
of handed Trump a way out if he wants it,
which is they got a retaliation on the record
for Kaseem Solemani.
It didn't lead to any casualties.
And now if Trump wants to gracefully exit
without doing more, he can do it maybe without
feeling like he's a beta male as, as the,
the those on the right mind say, and if he's
determined to escalate, he also can.
And it seems as though he doesn't seem that
interested in escalating as of right now.
Yeah.
But that wasn't really my question.
Like my main question is like kind of this
huge speculation territory.
Like, like we don't really know what the future
holds, but like let's just speculate.
Worst case scenario, if like there is like
some sort of all out war with Iran, uh, do
you think there would end up being like some,
any sort of use of selective service like
AKA the draft because like, like personally
I don't really think so.
No, I don't think so either.
Yeah, I did.
I did a live stream earlier this week and
a lot of people were talking about the draft.
Could I get drafted?
What's going?
I don't think the, the, um, the volunteer
military in the United States, both, thankfully
and concerningly like why so many people want
to be in the military is an area of concern,
although some are doing it for economic reasons
and, okay, we can talk about that.
But also fortunately the volunteer military
is so big that the size of the armed conflict
that that would necessitate a draft would
be so huge that I don't think that that's
a likely outcome at all.
Even if there's a major escalation with Ron.
I don't see a draft.
Yeah.
I mean we haven't used it in like what, six
years or something like that.
Yeah,
well it was done in Vietnam.
That wasn't 60 years ago, but
Oh, I dunno, I got my numbers wrong.
Sorry.
I'm like, I'm really mainly asking this cause
like I'm 18 year old college student, go to
Yukon, go Huskies.
So like a lot of people I know are kind of
concerned about this whole thing.
[inaudible]
I totally get it.
I, I do not as based on everything we know
right now.
I don't think you have to worry.
I really don't.
Yeah.
Like I, I understand like the concern from
some people, but I honestly don't think like
it would end up being an issue.
I just wanted to know your opinion on the
whole thing.
All right, very good.
Well, that's, uh, I, I hope that I am not
wrong because if I'm wrong on this, a lot
of people have some very ugly things coming
up.
Uh, so, so I hope that I'm right on this.
Oh yeah.
[inaudible]
all right.
Thanks very much.
Appreciate the phone call.
I apologize to everybody I was not able to
get to, but I am out of time.
We will take calls again.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
more right after this